d'état fête de la musique à paris des
concerts improvisés mais aussi les
manifestations un peu plus officiel
quelques images de l'édition 90
notamment en rude valoir au ministère de
la culture puisque c'est jack lang qui
avait lancé cette idée il y a neuf
commentaires thierry ce temple hare
concerts annulés dans la cour de l'hôtel
matignon personne n'a été épargné par la
pluie ce soir
ce qui n'a pas empêché michel rocard de
décorer g6 norman de la légion d'honneur
remerciements de la cantatrice
là haut un roi au one two eyes la wii
mais les lambris ministériel peuvent
aussi receler de sacrées surprises 22
heures rue de valois amitié guerre très
décontracté accompagné par ses enfants
est là lui aussi
la musique c'est une bonne idée
comment avez vous trouvé l'accueil des
des français y asseoir marseille c'est
plus chaleureux à chaleur et les masses
et m
j'espère que paris même et même plus
cher est-ce que l'europe en jeunes
conservent jeunes mick jagger
je sais je sais mes films français
jeunes jouent ailleurs dans paris la
musique partout comme ici à la bastille
alors il n'est pas trop tard pour sortir
la nuit ne fait que commencer